[Música]
qué es la importancia
a ver para ustedes que es la importancia
que es ser importante
podrían decirme
par de sinónimos como trascendental
enorme famoso poderoso grande
y así podríamos seguir diciendo palabras
al aire pero cuál es la verdadera
importancia que existe en cada uno de
nosotros
cuando yo tenía más o menos su verdad
creía que quería estudiar derecho o
historia del arte porque creía que mi
papá tenía esas expectativas sobre mí
cuando estaba en último año de
preparatoria me metía al taller de
teatro musical de la escuela y me
escogieron para hacer la protagonista o
una de las protagonistas de la obra
fue ahí cuando supe que quería ser
actriz
yo tenía mucho miedo de decirle a mi
papá que quería ser actriz porque juraba
que me iba a decir no mijita tú vas a
ser abogada
entonces un día me armé de valor baje al
cuarto de la tele y le dije papá quiero
hablar contigo
y me pregunta qué pasó y yo es que
quiero ser actriz
se me quedó viendo apagó la televisión y
me dijo eso es lo que te va a ser feliz
sí
si eso es lo que te va a ser feliz y es
lo que te apasiona hazlo en ese momento
mi papá me dio el poder y la libertad de
hacer lo que yo quería entonces eso hice
después de estudiar dos carreras de
actuación hice mi primer película
gracias a dios fue muy exitosa y a raíz
de eso tuve mucho trabajo ise novelas
series
y obras de teatro
pero qué pasaba mientras yo tenía esos
proyectos un día tenía trabajo y me
sentía importantísima
me sentía valiosísima mi autoestima
estaba en el cielo la gente me trataba
diferente todos se querían tomar fotos
conmigo
y que pasaba al día siguiente que yo ya
no tenía trabajo porque en el ínter que
tú terminas un proyecto y él comienza el
otro pasa un tiempo y no sabes cuánto
tiempo va a ser en ese ínter yo me
sentía completamente devaluada mi
autoestima se iba al piso
completamente vacía sin importancia
que estaba pasando yo pensaba porque si
yo le dije a mi papá que iba a ser feliz
estudiando actuación no estoy
disfrutando esto que me encanta y que me
apasiona como debería
me di cuenta que estaba viviendo en una
inestabilidad emocional muy fuerte un
día estaba en el cielo y al otro día
estaba en el suelo
eso desató en mí ataques de pánico y
ataques de ansiedad que poco a poco
fueron cada vez más fuertes
no sabía cómo controlarlos entonces tomé
la decisión de darle un break a mi
carrera para encontrar esa estabilidad
emocional que yo tanto estaba buscando
muchos me dirían crisis pero porque si
tú eres exitosísima famosa sales en la
tele haces películas haces teatro
pues así me sentía completamente
deprimida no me la creía tenía una
necesidad abrumadora por ser aceptada
por los demás por ser perfecta quería
que todos dijeran juancris es perfecta y
yo me veía en el espejo y sabía que no
era así
era demasiada la presión
me hacía muchas preguntas quién soy qué
quiero cuáles son las expectativas que
tengo sobre mí cuáles son las
expectativas que los demás tienen sobre
mí
fue entonces cuando decidí hacer cosas
que me dieran paz como abordar gracias a
eso hoy tengo un taller en donde hago
tocados y accesorios hechos a mano
más o menos en ese ínter conocí a mi
novio que ahora es mi esposo
y de la mano con él y junto con él hemos
descubierto la llave de nuestra
felicidad saber que no somos importantes
les voy a poner un ejemplo que para mí
es muy claro
cierren los ojos
imagina que estás en un avión está
sentado en la ventanilla de ese avión
estás viendo hacia afuera ves a todas
esas personas que trabajan en la pista
de despegue
el avión comienza a avanzar y comienza a
despegar empieza a subir
entre más sube tú vas viendo esa pista
de despegue esas personas que trabajan
en la pista de despegue cada vez más
pequeñas
el aeropuerto las casas los coches las
personas que caminan en la calle todo se
comienza a ver cada vez más pequeño
cómo te sientes en este momento
ahora imagina que este avión tiene la
capacidad de subir más y se va la luna
tu volteas por la ventanilla del avión y
buscas tu casa tus coches tus cosas
importantísimas que tienes guardadas en
tu closet
solamente se ve el planeta tierra
una bola
con agua tierra y nubes
ahora imagina que este avión puede subir
todavía más si se va al espacio
volteas a buscar tu casa tus coches esas
personas que caminan en la calle y
solamente puedes ver un puntito en medio
de la vía láctea cómo te sientes ahora
chiquito verdad
ya puedes abrir los ojos
cada vez que pienso en esto y entre más
pongo mi vida en perspectiva al mundo me
doy cuenta que mi vida no es
indispensable para que la vida en
general continúe
cuando tengo miedo me acuerdo de esto y
entonces este miedo disminuye y ahí me
doy cuenta que mis posibilidades son
infinitas
es cuando empieza la magia me vuelvo
completamente poderosa valiente y capaz
y por supuesto descubro la libertad que
existe dentro de mí y me permito ser yo
misma
muchas veces basamos nuestra importancia
en la gente que está más cerca de
nosotros en nuestro círculo más cercano
en nuestra familia en nuestros papás
maestros amigos en este caso yo pasé
toda mi importancia en la opinión que mi
papá tuviera sobre mí
ese día cuando yo le dije que quería ser
actriz él pudo ver la importancia de la
libertad que hay dentro de mí
todas esas expectativas
juicios opiniones de los demás
me doy cuenta que solamente están en mi
mente
y entonces llega a mí esta pregunta soy
o no soy importante
la verdad es que sí y la verdad es que
no
que estaba pasando cuando un día que
tenía trabajo y me sentía importantísima
y al otro día que no tenía trabajo y me
sentía completamente devaluada estaba
basando todo mi valor y toda mi
importancia afuera de mí
me di cuenta que la importancia que
tengo es únicamente la importancia que
yo me doy y no la importancia que los
demás me den entonces ya no me importa
ser importante para nadie solo para mí
fue ahí cuando acepté quién soy
que quiero y que me gusta
buscando la palabra importancia en el
diccionario
podemos ver que es una palabra que viene
del latín y es el fruto de la suma de
tres partes y que significa hacia
adentro portaré que significa llevar ya
que significa cualidad
entonces volviendo a la pregunta inicial
qué es la importancia importancia es una
cualidad que tengo dentro de mí
yo los invito a todos y cada uno de
ustedes que descubran esa cualidad que
llevan dentro para que el día de mañana
puedan ver con mayor claridad las
situaciones que se les presenta en la
vida no basen su importancia en la fama
o en cosas materiales ni tampoco en
juicios o en opiniones
que los demás emitan sobre ustedes
entonces encuentren su verdadero valor y
descubran ahí la libertad interior
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]